all right thank you very much for having
me mmm my name is Richard Satori I am an
angular developer it's Donna Bank I am
fairly new in the industry but yeah I've
played around with different tech and
today I'm just here to basically share
my story about some of the things that
I've discovered along the way yeah
here's my twitter handle if you want to
know anything anything about this
presentation afterwards you can reach
out to me we've got a few slides so I
will go through rather quickly but yeah
feel free to stop me to ask questions if
you have any or you can save them for
for afterwards all right let's jump
right into it oh another thing before we
continue is that I notice that we have a
few GD easier so if you have any hard
questions please just put anything funny
to them alright so yeah GD is Google
developer experts they are there is if
you are on here so please point those
difficult questions to them anyway um
agenda so I'm gonna take you through
basically a this is a very opinionated
presentation in other words it's it's a
spec which I've chosen and have build
applications with it and so I'm going to
take you through quickly through angular
for those of you that I have not used it
before and then we'll talk a little bit
about firebase and what it entails and
all its features after that I will
introduce you to a wrapper which is
called angular fire to will talk a
little bit about offline first
strategies using the serviceworker and
then after that we will build a hacker
news PWA so there's a demo
coming up after that we will do some
we'll basically just benchmark that PDA
PWA to see how it stacks up in terms of
performance and then we'll use
lighthouse and other tools to optimize
and see how we can improve the input
type a form ins
yeah we'll test this tech which is
pretty much what I've just mentioned now
and then we'll share some some lending
some learnings and findings and I'll
also show you some resources where you
can learn more about this technology
stack alright so moving right into it
the stack JavaScript frameworks there's
quite a few of these and sometimes it
feels like there's a new one coming out
every second week actually the one
there's one that comes up quite
frequently but I think it's arguably you
can say these three are pretty popular I
got the screenshot from the other day
from John popper he did a little so I
was looking for a what do you call it a
cloud wait loud four full different
JavaScript frameworks I couldn't find
one and then I happen to come across
this and I asked John popper if he if I
can use it and this was his response he
says of course but keep in mind that
poles are not perfect this captures
people on Twitter who follow me who
happened to see it and who wants to
reply which I think was pretty face I
thought of putting that disclaimer but I
think if you look at other comparison or
polls react is pretty much in front but
this is not a popularity contest it's
you know it's about you know using a
framework that is fit for papers and
clearly you can see which one I I went
for so that's what we're going to talk
about tonight angular so you might be
asking yourself why angular for those
that have not used angular before
angular is for me personally I actually
started with view I did a few for couple
of for a short while but then cause of
work I had to move on to angular which I
love
to bits at the moment I'm still learning
it so correct me if I you know miss
spell or miss say some things but
basically I never hood this is basically
the the basic components of of an
angular that the most basic one is an
angular module or ng module comprises of
a template and a component which gives
you your angular view we use event
windings to take input from the user and
we process it through in the component
and then we'll retain application data
if I have property bindings directives
and banks you basically just it's some
logic on business logic that modifies
your template before you relate to your
user it has this very cool piece of
technology called dependency injection
and that allows you to use shareable
services which you can import into your
component it helps keep your component
nice and dry and you can reuse them so
the idea is basically just you know if
you have a specific feature maybe user
login you want to keep that as a single
module for these benefits for that which
I will delve into in the next couple of
slides but yeah basically that is
angular under the hood the most the most
benefits that people are ways is exactly
what it say is there you're able to use
your angular skills to basically build
for not only mobile not only web but
mobile and native desktop as well it is
possible
things like ionic they heavily use this
under the hood angular by design is
built for speed and performance if you
add things like web workers and service
workers and server-side rendering you
just basically make you up you can make
your applications pretty fast other
benefits or other reasons why people
love angular is because of its
incredible tooling and it's community
behind it I mean we've got the angular
CLI I think it's one of the most
beautiful pieces of software with the
latest release of angular 6 with edits
extra features like schematics and
elements and all those kind of stuff
which I'll delve into in later slides
and it's loved by millions myself in
some of the web developers here I hope
you have tried it if you haven't tried
it please dive in and and have a look at
it
angular door IO is the website you want
to go to you to get
so the next piece of technology that I'm
going to talk about is firebase how many
of you have used firebase before ok
quite a few cool have you use all the
features that are they at the moment
night ok so uh right absolutely so
that's yeah I've going through that
routes I've tried to use all of the
features that are available for the web
but it's basically if you don't know
what rapid firebase is you can think of
it as a back-end is a service so if you
do not want to tinker with provisioning
servers and infrastructure and managing
all of that you people who've worked in
big organizations we you know you're
saving millions of customers you will
know that you know as your application
grows or as your user base grows so does
your infrastructure but firebase allows
you well it basically abstract that
layer for you because you know it's a
beckon as a service so you're able to
build applications fast without managing
infrastructure it is backed by Google
yeah and and and I think the one cool
thing with with firebase is the fact
that you know most of the features they
work nicely together
as you'll see now the first one that
I'll quickly touch on is authentication
education is basically just you know
managing you user authentication the
cool thing with this I think it's the
fact that you have you can use multiple
providers whether be Google Twitter I'm
not sure Facebook is there yes as well
if say you will also want to use
password list so you don't want to use
this to to create a password you can use
that as well or you can go old school
and use it you know your email and
password the next feature is the
firestone cloud firestone this is the
actual database that you interact with
the the nice thing with the database is
that it's a known sequel database it's
based on the concept of connections
connections you can think of it as a
jason object within collections you have
actual documents document this way you
would store your ID or user
ID email address and all the other
properties that you wanna store for the
user and then cloud storage so if you
want say say you have an application
that you you know you you offer file
uploads you can use cloud storage to to
store those images
couple that with cloud functions which
is one of my favorite features is that
so stop functions is basically you can
think of it as like web hooks so you
imagine a scenario way you offer a
client's oh it's an it's an image
sharing service or application typically
users will upload anything that they can
as long as this is see an upload they
can put in anything in this with cloud
functions you're able to basically
detect what they are uploading the size
and and file format and you can do some
sort of transformations before you store
it up into your storage and you can also
create records in your fire store
database once you're done building your
application and you want to host it you
can do so the firebase offers hosting
service which is very very generous here
very cool thing is with this is that
they've got City and distributed
globally so as soon as you upload you
your your application it basically gets
distributed across the globe to be their
CDN Network and that means for your
users that in regardless whether you
here on in Dallas or in China you know
you can just pretty much have a low
latency access to their application and
your assets which is a very cool thing a
market I heard through the slogan that
someone is gonna do a talk on that we
don't have it in web as yet correct me
if I'm right
yeah but I think it might be in the
pipeline I hope yeah we'll see the
future is bright for five days
all right now just give me a sec who of
you have had of angularfire
or have used angular fire before in your
application okay I see one two hands
Anglophile is basically fire too because
we
that's the latest one is basically it's
a marriage between angular in five and
five days
it's an angular wrapper for firebase so
all those features that I've just spoken
about just now your authentication your
database storage and all that stuff it's
they're all available but you because we
are angular developers we like to do
things the angular way so we built a
wrapper for it the cool thing with this
library is the fact that it is it is an
official library it is developed by the
guys I think David David East is one of
them and the angler core team and many
other guys from from google as well use
it the one thing that I will show later
on what I like about it about this
wrapper is the persistence so you just
call in one method and allows your
application to to basically persist your
data so imagine you busy capturing a
form and all of a sudden Telecom I mean
s chrome decides to cut electricity and
you you don't have an internet
connection all of a sudden it will
persist your application once the
connection comes back you well you'll be
able to access that the locally cached
data from the from your fire store
database and once the internet
connection comes back on then you'll be
able to you know continue where you left
off which is it's a very good cool
feature it's purely pretty popular this
was taken about a week ago I think it's
just over $17,000 a week
it's currently at RC release candidate
11 but they move pretty fast so by the
time you go and check it out it might
don't twelve there have been some
breaking changes in the past I learned
the hard way but yeah it's something
that you need to keep in mind but it is
it's got a very good support and
community behind it how am i doing on
time all right
how would you get it in your projects
you do it like that the nice thing about
it is that you only import the stuff
that you need so if your application
only uses
the database module you only need to
install angularfire store module if it's
authentication or storage you just
import the stuff that you want to use
and to initiate it down there at the
bottom this is where you obviously enter
all your secrets and and whatnot
the nice thing also is the fact that you
do not have to so typically it would be
on your main module with angular you you
have at least one root module and one
root component but with you know
depending on your own the structure of
your application you you just make you
import this way you are using it in the
module that you want to use it for
benefits that we'll discuss shortly how
do you use it using it is pretty
straightforward if you've written if
you've worked with typescript before
this is what it looks like
angular by the way is also written in
types in typescript which gives you
strongly typed powers to make sure your
applications or your code is resilient
so to into to get started with angular
fire so you would because it's Eric's
j/s base so you'll have to have rxjs
you'll need angular fire store you just
import it like that and through
dependency injection you you pull it in
through your constructor and this is
what I was referring to earlier on
collection so this will be your
high-level JSON object in your database
and the name of the collection is items
and it's got this very nice methods that
you can call value changes will
basically return you an observable array
if you want I think there's another one
called snap short change I'm not 100%
sure what it's called but it'll return
that observable area with merit with
metadata as well so if you have ID
stored and all those kind of things you
will be able to pull them through as
well and to display it in your template
you just call it on ng for you iterate
through your observer but because then
observable you need to use the async
pipe to unwrap that and observable and
through interpret interpolation you be
able to extract all the data that you
need today so it's pretty
straightforward it's everyday code that
we write
if you use angular on a daily basis I
should not assume that lot of mobile
developers are looking at me like all
right moving along oh so yeah the time
has come for you no I think everyone is
looking forward to this but not quite it
if you still wide awake by now and if
you remember what I mentioned at the
beginning or is my agenda is that this
talk is not about angular and it's not
about five days it's not about pwace
it's about everything about using all
these technologies together to get the
most out of them so I'll just take
quickly take you through the
serviceworker specifically will focus
specifically on the angular
serviceworker in its simplest form a
serviceworker is simply a JavaScript
file it's a it's a J's file where you
define how your application how your
application requests requests Network
requests so basically intercepts network
requests and it stores the response into
your cache API that's that's its
simplest definition you know and you
might ask BR wondering why you want to
do that I think it's pretty much I think
it's for obvious reasons because cache
is obviously on your browser itself so
I'm talking about the browser cache so
the idea behind serviceworkers is that
you want to show something on the screen
as quickly as possible so first time
around when you make an API call the
service worker will jump in and say okay
let me have a look you want to make a
call to this API and it'll catch their
response and put it into the case API on
the browser itself so next time when you
request the same API all the same
address it'll basically look into the
cache or if it doesn't find the
information that it's looking for or the
cache has expired then it will make a
network all the cool thing with with the
angular service worker specific
is that you can define how all these
things work but first before we get to
that this is something that tricked me
over when I when I started looking into
service records it looks very simple it
is a simple diagram I think so basically
this is what happens when you
application loads the service worker
gets registered schedu installed and you
get activated and it starts doing its
magic but it's very important for us I
think for me I did this mean for me
actually because I think it's very
important that you understand how the
life cycle works because it's very easy
to get tripped over you you'll be
expecting a certain behavior I mean
while this thing is bringing back
something completely different so
depending on how you configure it and so
forth yeah it helps to basically
understand how the life cycle works
browser support who can tell me what's
wrong with that picture
[Music]
well except for that lonely outlie over
there I think everyone is in agreement
that this is a cool idea right so yeah I
think you guys can go ahead and use this
stuff because it is supported across oh
but I mean look at even Samsung internet
you know they're right they're right up
theirs or they've been suffering it
since four which is pretty cool so yeah
guys please go ahead and start tinkering
with this with this sort of stuff now so
we because we are angular developers we
will talk about sales I guess in the
context of angular so so if you look at
this stage there's a six six part it's
about six steps
most of these steps you would have to do
it by hand and not so long ago if I'm
not mistaken
in fact I am not mistaken because I had
to do something this stuff by hand but
with the latest angular angular 6 we
have added a new Costco Mattox basically
this angular /pwa so you just throw in
there you just go ng add angular PWA and
it basically goes ahead and does all the
stuff it configures and stuff for you
I think the one key thing that are maybe
is worth mentioning in this in the steps
is the manifest.json file as you will
see shortly so basically the manifest
Jason file it basically you that's where
you define how your app you you PW how
you want u p w8 to look like once it's
downloaded oh well actually if you if
you've come across a PW a is yet you
should have because most of the South
African websites they basically telling
their applications to pwace but
basically so you'll notice on the
address bar there you might you might
have like a same color theme with the
rest of the application so you define
those kind of things in that
manifest.json file another very
important file that that the ingre PW a
schematic does for you is create this ng
SW config a JSON file this is if you
remember what I've mentioned earlier on
what I said Allah one was that you can
basically tell the service worker how to
deal with network requests when to look
into the cache first or whether to look
into the cache face or if it should go
to the network face you define all those
kind of things all those things in the
ng SW config JSON file and once you've
done you just basically build the
project make sure you build it with
double - prod that allows you well it
builds their project in ahead of time
compilation basically just tree shakes
all the necessary polyfills and all that
other stuff that is not necessary for
you I have to run it makes it very lean
and then you just find the project yeah
so now let's I think let's look at what
is being cached are you guys still with
me I still following you have I lost you
completely please do you raise a hand if
um I'm moving too fast so if you've lost
me completely this is what is being a so
there's two groups so this is obviously
how angular I have decided to have
defined how to to cache your assets
there's two groups the first one is
called asset groups and subgroups
basically it it's it's where you
you save as' waker what to carry so you
all know your your app skeleton so if
you guys are not 100% showed a a web
application usually comprises of an
index HTML CSS and JavaScript files so
what we saying here especially it on the
install mode we're saying that as soon
as the application loads go ahead and
cache all this all this file so your
HTML in index.html anything that ends
with panel dot CSS and bundle jsn Chang
J's now we have another one here called
assets this one's install mode is lazy
what that means is that it you do not
immediately start cashing the stuff wait
until the user navigates so as soon as
the user navigates to a certain URL
certain path then it will cache those
assets the other group is called data
groups in data groups we have two types
the first one is called freshness or
uses strategy called freshness and
simple in simplest terms it just means
network first so go into the network
first and so in this specific example
you know when you hit that URL go to the
nitrate don't look into the cache first
and yeah you can also specify you
through the cache config the max max age
and the timeout so after 10 seconds if
this thing doesn't return anything you
don't look into the cache the other the
other option is performance this is for
all the other the remaining roots of
your application however many you want
this one will look into the cache face
so it'll say cache if the max age has
expired
excuse me then it will go out to the
network and fetch those assets all right
moving along if you've done everything
correctly then you will you know you
look at the when you look at your dev
tools you look at something like this as
you can see here we are in offline mode
so this prior to this you would
have to have gone to the fs cuz
obviously it's the case from somewhere
else so you first have to visit the app
and it will catch that using that I said
group strategy it will catch all the the
the basic files and when you refresh and
then it will serve it from the Service
Worker so this is how you know that your
application is being served from the
Service Worker so what you're looking at
now is a good thing you want to see this
when you've is attend your application
to a PWA all right okay so I've covered
that so yes show the thing yes the demo
do you guys want to take out your phones
and go to that URL tiny URLs
yes you can use them side by side you
don't have to have one or the other they
can work in tandem
is everyone day okay awesome
so that is a PWA if you are lucky or if
you have a smartphone using a browser
which is up-to-date you might get a
little banner that ask you if you want
to add to your home screen have you guys
seen there okay you can go ahead and add
it if you want it's not a month but if
you want to see all these features all
come together that's yeah that's one of
the benefits of going the PWA route okay
cool yeah that that is a PWA so and if
you're accessing that URL through a
browser through a desktop and you run it
through lighthouse lighthouse let me
just quickly speak up a lighthouse is
basically it's one of the tools that you
can use to assess a website or web
applications performance and with that
specific one as you can see there that's
do you same URL that you guys went to
now I was done a couple of days ago so
it's all green so you want to be hearing
you know you want to have greens here so
the most important ones obviously here
is performance and progressive web you
don't have to check for this other stuff
but it's good to know it's you're all in
the green yeah I think the key metric
for me for this screen is well I think
not just for me but like for most
application is time to interactive what
that means is that you know how long
does it take for your application to
become to get to a state where it's
responsive to user input so you want to
have that definitely degree in fact if
it's over ten seconds right now it's
four point six milliseconds if it's over
ten then you'll start affecting your
progressive web app matrix so this will
probably go down to right seven eight or
something like that and then at the
bottom here you see this is a foam strip
it shows you the timeline shows you how
quick your application loaded first
meaningful so another very cool thing
about matrix performance matrix
specifically things like Netflix
tvu I so they have specific matrix that
they've decided to focus on and optimize
for them is TTT I is as it's also known
they also look at if I'm not mistaken is
that estimated input latency or input
responsiveness so it's how long it takes
when a user taps on something how
quickly does the application respond for
them that is very important and then
also the CPU usage so those are the
three ones that the track so every
application will obviously be different
depending on you know what you
optimizing for what what the app does
and what what do you use our base look
like but you know it's always good to
have greens all right I just like
looking at the greens all right so if
you're not getting those greens guys
this is some of the ideas that you can
follow to basically get to the greens
the first one is called a purple pattern
I really enjoyed your you talk mr.
Geiser yeah I talked a little bit about
the purple person but it's pretty cool
so the idea is I think it's it's it's
always been there but I think it was
coined the first time at Google i/o 2016
by the polymer team and the idea is
basically and you'll see how this all
comes together it's you push critical
resources first so your apps show the
asset groups you render initial routes
with a very lean app module so in the in
the angular context is that you know on
your mount on your core module you don't
want to have as many dependent or
imports in May you want to have you know
you want to keep it as lean as possible
you precache the the remaining roots
with the serviceworker and then you lazy
load the roots with a new modules so
this goes back to that idea of you know
making sure that you keep all the
features together and motorize your
application that helps you to basically
apply the lazy loading in those kind of
stuff this is just basically a diagram
that shows you how your application
loads you first get the index.html well
you guys saw the splash screen right
towards the splash screen then
that's contained within the index.html
file your up your app module gets loaded
and then obvious our other stuff happens
but eventually you get two fully
interactive which is in my opinion that
you know you want to get there as
quickly as possible all right now you
may be wondering where do I start off
with an existing application but you
know how do I know how it's performing
you can do a bundle analysis you install
webpack bundle analyzer through NPM you
add that to your jason package.json file
and then you run the analyzer this will
basically scan through your node modules
will scan through all your files your
application and it will give you it will
give you a breakdown of the you know the
the size of your application so you will
get something that looks like this this
is is for that and I can use PWA
as you can see here angular is the
biggest stick in the bigger space
closely followed by firebase and you've
got all this other files as well and
there's your source file they so clearly
I mean just by looking at this you can
say okay so maybe I should be thinking
about lazy loading firebase or motorized
in that part so that I can I don't have
to load it immediately when the app
launches so that's something that I
would do out first I would make sure
that that is a separate module and by
doing so you basically cut your the
bundle size in half or roundabout
this is another tool this is a very very
cool tool tool I actually got to play a
little bit more with it today and I
discovered new features isn't going
along it's so excited but basically so
this basically I know you put in a URL
you can specify the sort of connection
so think about you user base let's say
you're a big company and you've got
users all over the world and let's say
business is starting to become sluggish
in a certain geography and you want to
find out how you up your it's obviously
an online shop or online application and
you want to find out how are people
experiencing
application within that geography so you
can specify basically the type of
network connections that are our typical
within that area
once you've done there once ofrenda and
I'm just going to show you one example
this many things that you can do with it
you'll get something like this which is
called a waterfall view basically shows
you how you add your application loads
so once it connects it it first loads
your HTML you see it's pretty quick so
because I've inlined everything the CSS
HTML you can see that you get a face
paint very quickly you know just under
half a second half a second so that's
that's your HTML loaded and then it it
does your pausing compiling and
rendering your JavaScript that is
actually the the biggest chunk of work
with browsers javascript is if you can
optimize that part if there's any part
that you can optimize it should be that
that part through things like lazy
loading and all the other things that
we've discussed before but you can see
here our application gets fully
interactive run about run about they
yeah so this is this one of the tools
that you can use there's many others
there's also website grader comm it
gives you similar matrix but it goes
into detail in terms of you know what's
the reasoning behind the second Matrix
if you old-school you can still use your
dev you dev tools yeah so this one is
very similar the cool thing with that
first one that I showed you this one is
that you can actually simulate what dev
tool does under the hood most of it
actually is is is encapsulated in D but
yeah you can also do it that way I think
where you want to focus in is just
obviously looking at how you your
application gets loaded and then you'll
be able to well you identify the weight
that browsers taking long or the
application is taking long to getting
loaded and you can optimize for those
things this is one talk that I really
enjoyed is by a guy called Maxime sunny
curve
he's an angular gde yeah so he basically
goes in
detail all the stuff that I've done that
I've covered or the slides that I've
covered so far he does a little bit
deeper into those so I would strongly
suggest that you check out this
presentation very cool so what ever
learned I'm asking you the question
whatever you nothing all right
what I've learned is that so to get
started I think you know it's you wanna
let's say you've got a big application
or you've got an existing application
you don't know where to start I would
say you know look look at this quadrant
look at where this law low-effort
and when you get the most value
high-impact so go for their low-hanging
fruit by using the things that we've
discussed following the purple pattern
modularizing your application laser
loading those kind of funky stuff you
more value by doing so angular maybe I
should also add that angular does have a
style guide basically best practices of
how you structure your angular
applications yeah it I would strongly
recommend that you follow that as well
by default you'll basically build very
optimum applications what's coming next
Mike what's coming next
I mean with
Inglis six is was released recently and
whether it came a pretty cool stuff like
schematics you've already seen it's how
we do the PWA stuff elements is also
another cool feature that you can use
today going into the future I think I
don't know I haven't been following very
closely lately but I think they will
optimize all the tools all the new cool
shiny stuff that we have now I think
they'll continue optimizing them and
making them better and introducing new
stuff as we go along so I would say you
know Google angular the i/o for angular
stuff
firebase website for all the cool stuff
coming out from firebase as a as a side
note as well today or was yesterday
David East tweeted said if you using
this is if you're using firebase I've
got its new things secret thing but you
know if you want to know what it is
DME so I cannot freaking wait I did the
this morning but yes I'm still waiting
to see what the hell it is but I'm
pretty excited I'm sure it's gonna be
fine I think at this moment I should
want to take a moment to say thanks to
people that have helped me along this
journey Jeff is very very cool cool guys
got any on angular fire to calm he has
tons of of tutorials of willing material
yeah he's simply the basis he's very
good at what it what it does make seems
help me with some pwace tough questions
John Papa I like listening to him and
his adventures of angular podcast yeah
and also my teammates at Standard Bank
we have the wealth team web team and
free code camp free code camp is a
nonprofit organization if you're new
into programming or if you want to or
you just started and you want to you
know hang out with people in a similar
boat I actually try and organize one's
mind made up we made at Rose Bank just
basically just networking but there is
if you go to a free quad-cam blog you
can basically get started in this
journey there was a gentleman that
mentioned they don't that is not from
there it's not in the web space that's
how I got started self-taught but I
really enjoy what I'm what I'm doing now
and yeah and obviously you guys GD G
Joanna's back thanks for the invitation
I really appreciate that yeah and I've
got some resources for you so if you
look at an app that you download it
right at the bottom the source code that
will take you to to github my github
account if you want to optimize when you
wanna help me out with something
just send me a pull request I'll be
happy to match it yeah and with that I'd
like to say thank you very much and I
cannot wait to see what you build next
thank you
[Applause]
any questions
yep if he says can you just repeat the
question yeah yeah yeah no okay so the
service weight or the angular service
worker you don't I should have should I
don't have to slide but anyway there's
when you look at this Service Worker
file that that angular generates for you
it's about correct me if I'm wrong it's
about 2,000 lines of code you don't have
to touch that if you want to get to the
nitty gritties or video if you wanna add
some your some of your own stuff what is
cool white box white box what a white
box there's other similar tools but you
can go that way it is possible to use
more than one Jeff the guy that I showed
in Iran it is got a video on that but
yeah I think white box if you want to
just really get into the nitty gritties
of it you can do it you can go that
route yeah yes yes so you saw that
lifecycle right it is really so they
only show the main components but this
is sort of like interim steps that
happen in between you and you are able
to intercept those and you know just add
event listeners basically and then you
can respond depending on the state of
the service maker or the network request
in other questions
what is what is this oh yes yes if I'm
not mistaken right so things works or
not so there's an SDK the firebase SDK
you can just download it download it and
then you can interact with the with the
firebase that I know with cloud
functions they definitely they use so in
that case you specifically interested on
the upload status how for you all so
what you
I don't know but this English worker oh
yes no no definitely absolutely we at
the bank we use a lot of some features
he ran away when they introduced me yes
you can't use the reproduction I've used
so everything that I've shown you now I
know I've showed you a sort of like a
toy app but I'm I'm this is still under
production I've build something for a
nonprofit organization it uses all the
features for angular I mean it used
angular fire to with all the features we
don't have internet connection but yeah
anyway but it's it is ready for product
you can use it today
[Music]
well if it's good for Google I think
it's pretty safe I think maybe or
nothing that I didn't mention was the
fact that with with angular specifically
they you know most of the apps within
Google they they build using angular so
before they release a new feature
they'll have to make sure that they
don't break in all those apps so you
know with that rigorous testing I think
you know it's pretty safe for us to use
as well
[Applause]